President Trump wants places of worship  to open back up and today he made his  stance very clear take a listen  today I'm identifying houses of worship  churches synagogues and mosques as  essential places that provide essential  services some governor's have deemed  liquor stores and abortion clinics is  essential but have left our churches and  other houses of worship it's now right  President Trump says he wants them back  open this weekend and if governors don't  follow the new federal recommendations  he'll override them now right now in  Nevada the governor is allowing churches  to do drive up services out in the  parking lot  he's also allowing outdoor services with  proper social distancing in-person  services however inside a place of  worship are still not allowed